noi siamo
veloci
c'è gente che davanti a un cimitero si
fa il segno della croce
gente che se passa un carro funebre si
scartavetra le mutande a furia di
grattate noi abbiamo invitato un
becchino non tanto perché vogliamo
sapere quale sia il suo punto di vista
sul tema delicato della morte quanto su
quello e la sofferenza dell'amore ma
soprattutto della vita nome ragazzo oggi
che ospitiamo fabrizio fortunati non ci
credo faticoni mio fortunati perché
dei fortunati per lo meno e quindi ma
tra alto becchino cioè il nome tecnico
della professione non lo so è cosmetico
il nome dispregiativo dobbiamo chiedere
perché ci tenevamo sai come tipo b della
invece assistendo la batteria tipo
youtuber e contenti che
sì forse becchino non è la dicitura
giusta meglio chiediamo facciamo entrare
l'ospite ciao fabrizio tutto iniziò
allora avevamo subito una domanda la tua
professione tecnicamente becchino oppure
becchino e un dispregiativo nobel chi
non ha un vecchio modo per definire chi
si occupa di immobilizzare
pechino perché una volta il becchino
andava a casa si chinava sul morto
mordeva l'alluce del piede beccava con e
la gallina per vedere se era vivo o
morto non c'erano perché becchino
feticista ad oggi una persona che fa una
roba simile
livello avanzato perché in quel caso si
trattava anche di cadaveri quindi
fittamente cisterne cro filo per da mio
padre non era feticista eppure quando mi
dovrà sbrigare per andare a scuola mi sa
che io non mi voleva sarebbe renda per
il pollice mi tirava esatto e da allora
i nove dita di pietro
facciamo una luce
guardami agganciano a questo tuo
aneddoto di quando eri piccolo io voglio
sapere se da piccolo che volevi fare
forse avrei voluto fare da piccolo il
calciatore e quindi com'è che a un certo
punto è arrivata grazie al mio compagno
di banco che è proprietario di
un'agenzia papà faceva l'agenzia fune
perché hanno tuttora mia madre aveva il
banco di fiori e poi devo dire crescendo
perché non viene perché il milan a mano
perché diciamo che è stato sempre un
lavoro non proprio il primo lavoro ho
fatto sempre anche altre cose che da
giovanissimo ho lavorato tanto nei
locali notturni con i morti di [ __ ]
esatto io ho una domanda subito ma è
vero che si truccano a volte si beh si
cerca sempre di dare un'immagine serena
della persona che se n'è andata penso
anche per i familiari per gli amici po
per tutti a volte è talmente complicato
che non si non si espone neanche il
morto può capitare e come scusami se
posso truccare un io non lo faccio dice
che anche molto bravo e magari vede gli
omaccioni in rudy che invece
sì bellissima sta cosa perché tu magari
riconosci vedi
però sanno che quello spray aspetta
nuovi con una grazia che sembrano come
ballerini lanza classica proprio io
prima però di andare sul tecnico del suo
lavoro ti faccio una domanda pregressa
quanto pregiudizio cioè rispetto alla
tua professione che può essere tutto un
mondo di
superstizioso anche non banalmente
guarda più che perciò è la superstizione
il clutch e della classica cose vedono
passare il carro funebre quanto è vuoto
gratis e non è vuoto non di grattare
queste stupidaggini così ma più che
altro è forse le persone pensano sempre
che chi fa questo lavoro sia un po un
approfittatore
però è un lavoro come il wedding planner
organizzi un evento organizzi un evento
che purtroppo non è un evento felice
però la famiglia non si deve occupare di
nulla non si deve preoccupare di nulla
funerali
ce ne sono di tutti i tipi meno cioè
quali sono le cose che si selezionano i
fiori la bara i tessuti all'interno
della bara di tipo di umorismo che cazzo
me ne frega ma comunque a ritualizzare
un addio di base lo stesso ragionamento
lo puoi applicare e che ne so sul
matrimonio sta insieme da dieci anni che
senso ha quel giorno imbellettarsi ti
conosce anche in pigiama forse perché
speri quel giorno di non riconoscere a
ruota da sposa
per buona presa questa una volta carina
questa iv tappa qual è stato il funerale
più costoso che è stato mai chiesto mi
capita una volta una famiglia che ero
presente mentre si sta organizzando il
funari fecero un prezzo che era un
prezzo non basso ma non elevatissimo
però non basso medio alto medio alto e
familiare detto che mi sta dando
l'immondizia cioè quindi hanno dovuto a
un aumentato di fare e che stavano
diciamo che lo fu quello era intorno ai
12.000 euro e loro invece hanno speso e
pure 19
facemmo un preventivo di 6.000 euro cioè
cd cose vice ali sali con sali con la
qualità del modello la lavorazione con i
fiori i fiori se tu puoi scegliere una
margherita modo scegliere un orchidea
cioè puoi scegliere e anche lì tutto ha
un costo tutto nella macchina ti posso
garantire roma nord e roma sud c'è una
bella differenza se non a livello di
costi poco a livello di funeral juve
deve di delle scene in che modo sono
diversi i funerali di roma nord le fonti
di roma sud roma nord
un evento di come legante dove tutti
stanno un pochino giacche e cravatte o
magari li vedi con le loro l'alt ralph
lauren invece insulti ma capita la
signora che esce col moncler pigiama su
tetti e terreni chiesa così mi è
capitato scusate ragazzi vorreste i
vostri funerali ve lo posso chiedere se
tu ci hai pensato sì ma
io parlo per me e quindi ho tutto il
diritto di dire in che modo voglio
disporre della mia salma voglio giochi a
giocare perché le persone giochi a ripi
onda praticamente rip fionda ed il mio
corpo deve essere messo su una grande
fionda lanciato verso il cielo io credo
che questo potrebbe causare molti
problemi psicologici sui presenti però
se
ho pensato quale è una cosa che non si
fa oppure una una roba per cui tu metti
il mio corpo su una fionda e lo lanci
nel mare via via via pasta stop andate
avanti tutti che guardano altro lassini
e se vuoi puoi anche a prendermi
presente come che gli aerei quelli lì
che vanno sopra il gf un messaggio sulle
spalle che vuola dietro gli errori a mo
di mantello di super sì ma che tipo che
ne so dice vi voglio bene che direbbe
tipo vivalto voluto bene però conto che
lo dici perotto la spesa questo
sono l'aereo è il mio corpo e l'aereo
che viene sparato da dietro di te un
lungo striscione che dice tutto bene
finché non erano un po egoistico perché
lui è andato se ne va come vuole ma gli
altri vanno tutti i carcerati
in un pochino no
la facoltà di essere cremato di essere
di far sparire i centri dove vuoi
diciamolo ci sta ad essere onesti non ti
prende così male ci sta perché se la
gente lanciasse dei cadaveri nel mondo
tu immagina di camminare per strada i
cantanti e dc hanno un funerale che in
atto ci sta che non sia permessa una
cosa del genere ben tre voli tutti che
si fanno il segno della croce anche i
passanti
avete avete ragione avete ragione e
allora vi dico un'altra mi piacerebbe
che venga la fionda lanci
presentare verso il cielo cioè che tipo
milan ci nello spazio ma pari caschi
in orbita ricasca ufficiale cioè
bisognerebbe chiederlo massiccia non c'è
un'agenzia funebre
suoi come loro restano io non credo
nella vita dopo la morte ed è quindi
vorrei che le persone che rimangono se
ci sono perché magari muoio da solo non
lo so però se ci sono che dispone essere
un funerale come sia utile a loro una
ritualizzazione per dire addio a me cioè
che sia utile al loro funerale è utile
per chi resta non per chi se ne va
dipende che è persona saggia cornuto e
bianche avere un funerale senza nessuno
certo se si sera io non boh non sono
farei un funerale religioso fare tipo
presente le candele sul fiume carine
oppure la lanterna che va beh ci sono
paesi sono paesi dove fanno questo tipo
di simili non poi così certo oppure la
bara che va nel fiume con tutti i fiori
si ritrova all'improvviso che mentre
stanno vostri arriva un gommone con
satana spigola una classe 71 sarebbe
bello di questo sta giudicando lui che
una barca le candele e
[Musica]
si stacca la barca lancia verso il cielo
e poi in orbita chi funerale vorresti tu
ma guarda io avendo la passione per le
moto sono una resa quindi sicuramente un
casino ora in casino ma non in chiesa
non birra e
divertimento musica e vero che esiste la
possibilità di diamanti darsi sono vuole
se no a me non è mai capitato ho sentito
anche io questa cosa però è che diventi
un diamante al 20 in diamante di cure e
di vento in diamante anche
l'albero di 20 21 anni con fame tanto di
20 praticamente un albero di ambiente
però se tu prendi quel diamante è una
piccola fionda
le norme nessuno ti può dire nulla preso
ma se invece diventi una fionda ti fai
proprio modellare a mo di fionda
si fa chiamare un battare invece del
diamante invece l'albero di anti fionda
chiediamo scusa se questa chiacchiera ha
in qualche modo un trigger ato qualcuno
di voi ma oggi noi vogliamo
semplicemente parlare senza filtri per
cui invece alle altre volte stavamo
filtrati e mai successo qualcosa di
assurdo durante un funerale cose assurde
per parenti che ti chiedono ad esempio
dal punto di partenza arrivare in chiesa
non si può portare la bara aperta
che gianna domanda fuori cielo sì c'è
chi lo chiede una volta mi capitò questa
domanda rimanemmo tutti guardi non si
può
rimanemmo stupiti comunque perché chi è
che voi e il parente gira per roma si è
aperta una settimana dopo la stessa
domanda un'altra famiglia dico ma che
c'è un ben due volte nell'arco di una
settimana comunque io ho sempre pensato
che se dovessero
mettermi sotto terra e una bara allora 1
dovete accoltellarlo mini prima un po di
volte così sicuro solo morto passando il
tempo 2
campanella connessa da baraa su che nel
caso dovessi svegliarmi sono cioè tu
vuoi che le persone siano sicure che tu
sia muovendo un medico non basta no
quindi devi essere accoltellato comunque
ragazzi ho appena googlato tipo funerali
particolari nel mondo ho trovato questa
cosa il ballo con i morti in madagascar
e madagascar i morti hanno un ruolo
importante nella vita familiare a ogni
57 anni corpi vengono riesumati e i
membri della famiglia li spoglia non li
avvolgono con nuovi vesti suoi fan a
casa insieme tramonto i corpi vengono
seppelliti ma capovolti e la cripta ri
sigillata e ballano con queste ossa
ripuliscono foto ci sono ci sono delle
mummie trovi un po delle luci che
impressione però loro loro loro è una
cosa che fanno proprio con grande grande
fervore grande piacere agosto anch'io
turale giusto
la solita banalità paese che vai usanza
che trovi anche per quanto riguarda i
funerali dalla stessa cosa cioè ci sono
anche qui dei gruppi religiosi il morto
non lo tocchi ci pensano loro tu mi fai
gli organizza il funerale tutto volto ma
loro se lo lavano se lo vestono non te
lo fanno toccare comunque scusate io sto
continuano a trovare funerali in
particolari ho trovato che una famiglia
di questo certo christopher river amaro
ha voluto sottolineare il grande amore
del proprio caro per lo sport è affatto
la camera ardente in un ring
picchiassero ring oppure addirittura va
beh il finto funerale o questa
studentessa cinese che ha deciso che
voleva vedere chi avrebbe partecipato al
suo funerale si è tinta morta tempo fa
leggevo penso che lo puoi trovare di una
persona che è morta praticamente che
cosa fate come era un burlone si era me
credo messo d'accordo con la figlia
nella bara ha fatto mettere tipo un
registratore con la sua voce e quindi
quando stavano tutti sopra la alla tomba
e lei evidentemente ha spinto un
pulsante del partito lui che parlava di
ragazzi allora tiratemi fuori dai per
favore e poi di persona cosa hanno fatto
lo stupore iniziale poi poi dopo hanno
cominciato tutti a ridere che hanno
immaginato che erano scherzo insomma
anche chi fa questo lavoro se non l'hai
esercizi in qualche modo non vivi è
esatto ed è qui che si attenziona
domande che volevo fare com'è che fai tu
inizialmente una cosa che ti tocca e poi
pian piano diani sti tizi come fusero
devi per forza di cose un pochino
anestetizzati ci sono cose che non
riesci ad anestetizzare tipo le morti
giovani bambini una certa faccio io
faccio molta fatica mi è capitato più di
una volta e a volte mi devo coprire gli
occhi con gli occhiali che
inevitabilmente siamo anche noi esserlo
i lutti che abbiamo anche noi però
quando vedi una famiglia e perde un
figlio perde una persona giovane prima
che vi anche
pensi veramente che il mondo ingiusto
dall'altra parte ti aiuta torni a casa e
di ci sono fortunato un certo si aiuta
anche quello ad affrontare la vita in
maniera più a goderti magari può tutto
vi faccio una domanda contraria ti è mai
capitato di partecipare a un funerale
sereno c'è che fosse un bel momento di
addio sì soprattutto
con persone molto anziane che però non
ho avuto una vita magari piena
se un artista un
diciamo una persona che ha studiato
molto e che ha fatto molto nella vita da
quella che la tua esperienza qual è il
rimpianto che più spesso ti capita di
captare magari in vita non gli sono
stati molto vicino quanto avrebbero
potuto e voluto e quelli di quella
diventa una sorta di mea culpa nei
confronti della persona che non c'è più
poi muoiono tutte brave persone c'è mai
una finale di questo pezzo di m
scusate il termine
cioè ai funerali sono tutti bravi tutti
i buoni curi criminali sono verificati a
qualcuno i funerali in chiesa eccetera
eccetera voglio spezzare un attimo
questo momento per riportare in basso la
conversazione voi vi occupate anche di
tipo ii lapidi certo e degli epitaffi
cioè certo sì ci sono epitaffi
preconfezionati ultima frasi già fatte
esalto
ma ci sono pure famiglie che si sentono
trilussa o leopardi cosa scrivere ste
serafina non sono qui una fionda e ha
lanciato nello spazio
descriverei amo cazzo piangi poi tra
carte
ma io non lo so
io direi il buio dell'anima eccolo lì ma
quando sei scemo o console e adesso che
sono senza parole sito la musica dei
capi analizzi la questione pensando che
la mia
scomparsa non si sa fino a me stessa ma
utile a chi rimane la gestione del tutto
ciò vorrei che gli altri scegliessero in
base a quello che può essere utile a
loro adesso adesso tutti quanti dicono
sempre la stessa che cazzo ti guardi si
sia adesso tutti un po così scherzando
io invece per esempio fare proprio una
cosa che lei la tomba alla tua alla mia
destra c'è un in foto getty fissa
sistema resi così capito
sapete cosa m col botto la foto della
foto raga ma allora cosa scegliereste
voi perché tipo io penso che adesso per
una foto mia di adesso ed è certo
dimenticatevi di scegliere foto
solitamente le scelgo univale
riguardo su questa cosa se mi posso
permettere le famiglie sono da quello
che ho visto nella gran parte sono
abbastanza
diciamo delicati scelgono tutte foto
sorridenti tutte foto non certo non è
che mettono la foto della nonna 18 anni
camini con cinese legittima
perché ne può adesso parliamo di girare
donne le donne di oggi avevano vent'anni
negli anni sessanta quindi la minigonna
quindi michele tu perché foto mettereste
allora io
sulle foto
sestucci pensi il cimitero è stato il
primo vero instagram della storia perché
tutti mettono la versione migliore di là
sopra ma sulla base di un giudizio che
ha completamente estetico filtro beauty
palese a dio chiaramente la foto più
ritoccata che ho della mia figlia per
gli sono palesi state dicendo che tra
vent'anni metteremo tutte foto con la
bocca culo di gallina capire se
quello lì è più lollo mentre invece
michele più tipo un arto scomposto
all'internet di una cosa consiglia
vorrei una cosa concetto a tipo uno
scatto di michelle casinò si presenta
come una sorta di tazio di morte venezia
questo suo genere che risorse alle anzi
può si può mai fare si può fare chelsea
real ha mai chiesto la foto della statua
del defunto knox a mo di angelo tu lo
stai dicendo scusa la tua foto come
sarebbe
così sorridente comunque a questa buona
e un certo acqua e sapone e photoshop
denti bianchi sino a stato ce n'è molto
più noti bene
io per dire con mio nonno fatto questa
cosa che lui aveva questa fissa in
generale nella vita soprattutto
nell'ultimo periodo con i cornetti
algida un anno alla fine cioè tipo non
mangiava niente numeri lato un cornetto
algida cioè proprio era l'unica cosa che
voleva e quindi avevamo messo poi una
una scatola di cornetti algida
chiaramente senza il gelato
però i cornetti algida con l'ultima
confezione dell'ultimo cornetti know che
si era mangiato
la cosa è molto molto tenera
la mia era più calcistica per esempio
con mio padre che si cura della laziale
io sono romani siamo quasi tutti i
romanisti che è mio padre s'è lasciato
andare quando ha scoperto probabilmente
che mia madre sarebbe dovuto morire
perché si era ammalata e molto prima lui
e io gli dicevo sempre attenzione perché
se se non ti dai da fare per recuperare
ti metto i fiori giallorossi sulla bara
e alla fine quando è morto io mi si
capiva lazio spilletta della lazio la
sciarpa della lazio ma i fiori g
nella mia lapide avete presente la palla
quella 8 che lasi che
so magari faccio 50 audio che sono ne
sei sicuro
ora fossi in te ne fa ragazzi mio libro
delle risposte esatte quindi tu vai lì
premi guarda ho sentito cazzate migliori
o una domanda che vuole un pochino
cambiare rotta a voi qual è invece il
tuo rapporto con la vita come si dice il
bicchiere d'acqua quello che pieni in
mano mi chieda compresa nulla però se
quel bicchiere tu lo continuo a tenere
un
bicchiere ma c'è immagino quindi deve
cercare di andare avanti di viverla di
godertela si vive anche perché non può
vivere più sì penso anche quello sì un
paio di epitaffi simpatici allora
abbiamo un qui giace johnny ist scusate
se non mi alzo che è uno sconosciuto
carino alla carena signor marchese è
l'ora alberto sordi sì è vero dice la
skill perché si avvicina i miei genitori
davvero dove si salverà no al verano
riquadro prima di i miei genitori 15
passo sono perché se allora tema
califano sta uno dei più famosi non
escludo il ritorno
bellissimo
nelle bare
i cari possano mettere anche degli
oggetti all'interno
sì sì cioè allora beh vabbè c'è chi
mette magari classico rosario magari
mettere sigarette diciamo che ci sono
gruppi si può direttrici che mettono
soldi e oggetti di valore di grande
valore ha grande valore la quantità di
soldi una cosa strana che hai visto
all'interno di una bara che è stata
messa qualcosa non si può neanche dire
io una domanda magari una domanda un po
se
ti è mai capitato tipo qualcosa di
paranormale una cosa cioè non proprio
mai viste tipo uno spasmo di un corpo sì
ma lo siamo certi ti riconosci come
spazio di geni ultima domanda personale
qual è il tuo rapporto con la
superstizione non sono posso darti
un facile accesso no no
[Risate]
non sono granché sidel sessione non sono
granché se delizioso ai ragazzi no io no
cioè quando lo faccio lo faccio perché
faccio il cretino ma io
in
secca da un copione sbatti tre volte per
terra se avete però cosa non deve cadere
ma di andare nello spazio
eto'o collo con una bionda che verrà
disegnata apposta per fare per la prima
volta una spedizione spaziale di una
salma che aggiungo una cosa mentre di
lanciano accompagnamento musicale di
qualcuno che fa uil
infatti bravo voleva fare una richiesta
migliore vai puoi cantare che vuoi che
tanto
semplice
bella quella
appena faebook può
permettere allontanato devi pro salutare
ma perdono i partecipanti al funerale
saprai lanciato una presa con lui che
piange
capito tutti stupiti del fatto che sta
succedendo in questo momento di
spettacolo io piango si l'amica
distrutta ho capito io ti immagino una
sorta di capitò gestito benissimo tutto
in nero
dietro molto molto molto anziano ti
immagino
[Musica]
lei becco canto proprio secondo me la
tua voce rimarrà ha capito
benissimo
sarà fatto un cda adesso e magari la cui
si sa mai che ci sono cose così
un'ultima cosa che ti senti di dire
un'ultima c'è un ultimo messaggio che
vuoi lasciare un'ultima perla
a una qualcosa che magari non è detto
non è ribadito abbastanza non mi ha
chiesto una cosa divertente che per me è
stata divertendo tutte le mattine ancora
bisogno il primo ospite deve farsi
domande da solo io ti perdono no vabbè
per società tutto io ormai conosciamo
mela sono preparata proprio però no
quello che ti capita una volta andiamo a
casa di una persona anziana deceduta sai
di solito quelli che hanno le badanti
troviamo le badanti solitamente che
piangono un po per affetto un po perché
il loro licenziamento quello perché
c'era la badante sudamericana che rideva
rideva rideva accertati ho detto sia
signora ma perché è venuto spontaneo e
no perché sa la signora attore la
mattina lavagna io vado alle vantarla e
la signora e se fingeva morta e
stamattina la porta davvero
questa signora rideva finger se tutte le
mattine quando lei lo andava a svegliare
le si fingeva morta il co ana
la mattina invece era morta per davvero
quindi lei viveva su questa cosa per la
signora che stava morta stamattina
davvero grande ai era un bel fascia
sinistra
peccato non averla conosciuta in b non è
un genio se cose capitano è stato bello
mi sono divertito e grazie mille
grazie
è perché fa ridere che non secondo parte
quindi tu devi capito quindi se devo
mantenere maider facciamo una prova
facciamo devi fare poco quando il
pulsante la sconcezza rarissimo serio e
il mio funerale
tu che come ci sarà una foto di te che
piangi con dietro di te il cielo è una
cometa che va verso nord in
arrivo
io faccio tipo
mio marito
[Musica]
alleluia
e poi iniziò con la parte rep io bella
fra e deve deve cambiare proprio il mood
che io con la parte retta ok però già
suonato la tecnica che anche se rido
sembra che piango
pensato ragazzi che dirvi allora c'è chi
le pompe funebri le possiede chi invece
cerca di promuoverle quando si parla di
comunicazione anche di quelli che in
molti definiscono tabù il nostro
prossimo ospite è la prima persona che
viene in mente a parlare del potere
della parola della creazione desideri e
dell'importanza del messaggio sarà un
ragazzo che dal nulla fondato un'azienda
leader del marketing sul web un ragazzo
che è riuscito a mettere sulla
comunicazione un filtro nuovo che ci
permetterà di intavolare quella che già
si prospetta come una delle chiacchiere
più interessanti e controverse di questo
viaggio da noi feroce tutto ragazzi e
ragazze grazie
che s'è desta
no perché sanno
all'azione
alleluia
cambio d'abito via esatto e tu devi
salutare per in questo momento
così triste mentre e mentre canti e
gorgheggi saluti
esatto
ragazzi veramente mi faresti un fondo mi
fareste il favore della vita
[Musica]
[Applauso]